what we're starting to see is that like
individuals are losing control of
themselves and they don't even realize
that it's happening all they really see
is that like this is not exactly what I
want to be doing on a day-to-day basis I
have goals I have aspirations I have
things that I should be doing but I
can't seem to get away from a screen
Dr K welcome to the show it's an honor
to be here Chris it's been very
requested you are one of the most
requested guests I've had on the show
really really looking forward to this
I'm looking forward to it too I love
your podcast love the you know blend of
Science and sort of like personal
experience that you really put forward
here so huge fan thank you
what do you say when you meet somebody
at a cocktail party and they say what do
you do
uh so you know my stock answer is
actually like I'm a physician by
training
or
um or I say I work in digital Mental
Health
so digital mental health I imagine I
imagine that everybody knows what that
is well so that's the thing right is
it's like enough buzzwords to where it
kind of like people don't usually ask
questions after that so I think it kind
of depends on okay what am I really
looking for like do I want to talk about
myself right now
um sometimes I'll just say I'm a
psychiatrist
that's true
but you've updated yourself you are a
clinically trained psychiatrist who has
brought himself into the 21st century
I guess you could say that I think maybe
the the 21st century has brought me into
it is maybe a better way to put it but
yeah I think we're both kind of evolving
together at the frontier yes so you
spend an awful lot of time working with
Gamers people that use screens a lot in
a variety of capacities getting them to
improve their mental health getting them
to better understand what it is that
their motivations are why their brain
works the way that it does challenges
they're facing uh explanations about
mindfulness
from an outsider's perspective what is
it that most people don't understand
about Gamers and screens and mental
health and the relationship of how that
all works together
yeah so I think let's start actually
with like screens and Technology
so if we look at technology technology
tries to engage us right but if we look
at which organ
does technology interact with primarily
it interacts with the mind
and so what I think what a lot of people
don't understand is that our mind is
being accessed or activated or triggered
basically constantly all day every day
in a way that we just haven't evolved to
deal with
so if you sort of look at like the
natural environment in which the human
brain evolved it's like a low
stimulation environment like go for a
walk somewhere right and that's actually
the Baseline that we grew up in that we
evolved in and so all of this High
stimulation is
is working on us in some way and the
thing about our our minds is that if you
really think about this principle of
Engagement what does engagement mean
what are they engaging they're engaging
your mind
and as platforms get better and better
at this as video games get better and
better at this what we're starting to
see is that like individuals are losing
control of themselves and they don't
even realize that it's happening all
they really see is that like this is not
exactly what I want to be doing on a
day-to-day basis I have goals I have
aspirations I have things that I should
be doing but I can't seem to get away
from a screen
does something very ruthless about the
fact that the more enjoyable and the
better that screens and Technology get
at satisfying our desires the more
addicting they become which means that
although the felt present sense of how
good it was may increase the after the
fact remembered sense of how much it's
starting to intrude on our lives and our
other goals outside of the screens the
worse it gets it's kind of this
double-edged sword yeah I mean I I think
that captures it really well Chris so
like that that too if you kind of want
to take a step back like most technology
and especially video games are designed
to be fun
right but the human brain's capacity to
have fun like why do we have fun so if
you look at human beings and animals
we have fun we engage in play and we
engage in play to
practice the skills that are useful for
survival
and so what happens with video games is
is developers sort of figured out okay
like here's a game like a role-playing
game like an RPG and you know what we
can do to make it more fun we can make a
persistent Universe with thousands of
other players
and so what video games are what
developers actually stumbled upon is
like another sort of psychological need
this need for community and over time
exactly what you described as happening
is that as games become more and more
fun
how do they become more fun it's because
developers figure out okay we can
scratch like another psychological need
and so if you think about games like now
there's like appearance and cosmetics
right so we all want to look good
and since it triggers that sense of fun
what that sort of means is activating
that circuit the circuit that we have to
want to be respected to want to look
good except now we can sort of satisfy
it within a video game and what we're
starting to see is that like we can kind
of satisfy some of these psychological
needs in video games although they're
not like a complete satisfaction but
it's kind of enough and so what what's
sort of happening is people are like
starting to live their lives more and
more like in the virtual world and as
they do that they start to kind of get
disconnected or fall behind in the real
world
what are the mechanisms that screens are
working on and is there any difference
between the kind of triggers that video
games are having compared with the
triggers of other stuff like let's say
social media
yeah so I I think they're very different
so I think if you look at why does
someone get addicted to a particular
thing as opposed to another thing and
there are even studies that sort of bear
this out like so for example people on
the autism spectrum are more likely to
get addicted to role-playing games and
there's even data that shows that the
more role-playing games you play if
you're on the autism spectrum the more
likely you are to have behavioral
meltdowns So within video games we know
that there's actually personality
analysis like University of Toronto has
done a lot of really good research here
where they've sort of figured out
depending on your personality style
you're more likely to gravitate towards
a particular game and then once you move
Beyond games if you start to think about
social media you know people who are
more sensitive to body image issues May
gravitate towards platforms like
Instagram and things like that
um and so what we're starting to see is
that you know everyone's brain is a
little bit different everyone's brain is
a little bit vulnerable
um we all crave to have certain
psychological needs fulfilled and there
are certain pieces of technology which
will sort of fulfill those in a very
shallow but kind of neuroscientifically
important way and those are the ones
that we get addicted to
can you remember any of the other
associations between the type of games
that you like to play and the kind of
personality that you have oh yeah I mean
so like there are some people who like
to explore things right so that there
are people who
if we kind of think about it this way
let's say you take four trips over four
years do you go back to the same place
over and over and over again or do you
like to check out new places
right and there are different kinds of
people some people were like hey I
really liked that you know I love
visiting the beach or like every time I
go I'm gonna go to the beach I'm gonna
go to the beach I'm gonna go to the
beach there's a new beach
and so
some people are more exploratory and and
so there are certain kinds of adventure
games where you're kind of exploring
open World stuff they'll kind of get
more into that other people are like
optimizers so you have these games like
factorio and things like that where like
people are really they derive a lot of
pleasure out of taking something that's
at 70 and bumping it to 71 75 78 80 81
and these same people by the way like
you know companies like Google and
Netflix will pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars to do that thing for their
job how can we optimize this particular
widget on this particular app so that
depending on what your mind is
interested in or excited about some
people also seek adrenaline which is why
they'll play games like first person
shooters like fortnite
um so different brains want different
things and that'll absolutely determine
what kind of games you end up playing
what happens to your brain if you use
video games excessively
um so it in a nutshell not good things
but I think a lot of people will wonder
you know what is excessive
so this is where you have to understand
that the reason games are fun are
because they fulfill particular
psychological needs they like scratch
certain itches
and what the biggest problem that tends
to happen I know everyone talks about
dopamine and we'll get to that in a
second but the biggest problem that we
see is that once you start fulfilling
needs in the game
then your brain sort of has this really
tricky kind of situation because if you
try to fulfill that need in the real
world it's going to be harder what's an
example
so let's say I want to be number one
the problem is like in school there's
only one number one but in a video game
and if you all have played video games
you'll you'll sort of realize this like
when you come back from let's say you're
down and you're losing in a particular
game and then you come back and you win
there's this adrenaline rush and you'll
love it it's like one of the most
exciting things in the world
and the problem is like the like getting
that feeling of being like on the verge
of losing and then coming back and
winning
very hard to do in the real world
incredibly difficult to do and so these
are all these kinds of experiences that
We crave this sort of like you know
hero's journey of like the deck is
stacked against you but you're gonna
Triumph and this is what we love to see
in our media but like we can't
experience that in our everyday life
right because I've got to study for
calculus today and there's no like
Triumph like even if you sort of think
about reward circuitry and this is what
game game developers are really good at
so even if I get an A on the test
there's such a gap between taking the
test and getting the grade back that
that behavior doesn't get reinforced
whereas what we know from pavlovian
conditioning is that the faster you give
someone the reward the more likely you
are to you know
reinforce behavior and people wonder
like why is it hard to study it's
because there's no reward that you
experience
and and so I'm sort of I I even forget
what your original question was but I
think that Point's really smart that you
eat [__] now with the presentation for
work with the studying for the exam
which is in a couple of weeks time and
then at some point down the line that
one module of that one particular course
will finally contribute to the degree
that you get in two and a half years or
it'll it'll get you the job raise that
you need or the promotion that you want
in a couple of years time and maybe a
different company so I think that's
something that's very important uh what
I asked was what happens to your brain
if you use video games excessively you
said what you're doing basically is
um you can create a feedback loop of
satisfaction in the virtual world which
is incredibly difficult to replicate in
the real world I think that's what yeah
and and that's kind of I think the core
point is once you start using it
excessively
it becomes harder and harder to engage
in the real world and that's what we see
when it rises to the level of true
addiction and then there are all kinds
of other like neuroscience-based effects
that we kind of see so we'll see for
example alterations of like dopamine
reinforcement so people who play a lot
of video games will start to become a
little bit more anhedonic which means
that their ability to experience
pleasure sort of goes down so if you
play a bunch of video games reading a
book just won't keep your attention it
becomes harder to like do sort of IRL
stuff is that the some kind of dopamine
set point or dopamine sensitivity that's
being tuned down yeah so that that's
probably what's happening we don't we
you know we have a lot of
inferential data on this but no one is
like doing brain brain biopsy brain
biopsies of video Gamers and seeing how
much dopamine is in the synaptic Cloud
modernize yourself guys come on this is
the science [__] out but what we tend
to see is all the clinical features so
if you work with a gaming addict you'll
see like a lack of motivation and
motivation is primarily governed by like
dopamine and the nucleus accumbens
um we'll see anhedonia which is the
inability to enjoy particular things and
then other things that we tend to see is
that a lot of addiction is not actually
due to dopamine
um sort of making things fun so if you
talk to Gamers and I don't know if
you've ever binged video games but you
know people can play games I certainly
have for eight 12 hours at a stretch but
if you ask that person
hour five hour six hour seven are you
having fun they're not gonna be having
fun if you watch them they're not going
to be like smiling and laughing and
triumphing and in fact quite the
opposite what you're going to see is
that they're tilting more they're
getting more frustrated shorter
tilting is when you basically like get
really really angry and lose your focus
in a video game okay so in in
competitive Sports you know people will
like if you lose lose a point or
something you'll go and you'll be angry
and then people you'll start to play
poorly because you're not like focused
oh it's like getting The Yips in a
normal spot like baseball or whatever
the guy just can't hit yeah can't hit
that right okay so we have this scenario
in which
super normal stimuli have been able to
create a overclocked environment for our
brains to exist in we are unfit for
purpose we have a an Adaptive Pro we
have a mismatch in evolutionary
mismatches it would be called that what
we're able to enjoy virtually is
difficult to deliver to us in the real
world that means that the more time that
you spend online the more and more uh
unseductive and unattractive I suppose
the real world looks now
some of this is uh physiological in
terms of the adjustments that we've got
with dopamine sensitivity and stuff like
that but I imagine as well that a good
chunk of it is just the story that you
tell yourself about the kind of things
that you can do the
um the capacities that you believe that
you have the habits that you've got the
routine that you're in it's more than
just physiologically what's happening
it's like existentially what it's doing
to you so given that that's what's
happening with video games video games
you know created to be compelling I I
think people kind of understand that
there's a degree of entertainment there
something that probably even more people
have a problem with would be social
media is there something different
happening to the brain to our compulsion
with social media is it right to even
say that social media is an addiction is
it a compulsion how do you pass all of
this apart yeah so I think social media
is similar in some ways and different in
other ways I guess no surprise right so
if we once again what's similar so the
most similar thing is that platforms are
developing things that are more engaging
it's just what they engage with varies
depending on not only the specific type
of game but games versus social media
and even within social media you'll see
different kinds of Engagement
so generally speaking social media
engages with a couple of things the most
important thing that social media
engages with is emotional activation
so if you think about why does a human
being switch from let's say Twitter to
Reddit or Reddit to Twitter or Twitter
to tick tock or Reddit to tick tock what
you tend to see is that if you're
emotionally engaged you're gonna stay on
and if you get bored that's when you
switch but what does boredom usually
mean people may think it's dopamine but
it's not actually dopamine because a lot
of people will use a lot of social media
even though they feel really bad and the
best example of this is some people will
like break up with their ex right and
then like late at night you're feeling
bad about yourself and you start
stalking your ex that doesn't make you
feel good that's not dopamine and then
you see your ex out with someone else
who's more attractive than you or maybe
has a nicer car or something like that
and so a lot of people will actually if
you really tunnel down and there's
Research into this that shows that what
is the emotional experience of engaging
in social media it's not always positive
so if you really look at like what kind
of social media crosses your your feed
it's stuff that's emotionally engaging
we're hearing about war we're hearing
about climate change we're hearing about
something in some news organizations
even like play into this right where
like fear-mongering is a thing
and and so what we start to see is it's
really emotional engagement that social
media like really captures
um and so the people who are kind of
vulnerable to being emotionally engaged
will will sort of get caught up in
social media
another thing that we tend to see is
that the human identity and you kind of
alluded to this existential point
so like
social media allows us to create a
virtual identity and we can start to get
reinforcement of like these years of
millions of years of evolutionary
circuitry through the internet
so I want to be well respected in
Psychiatry or let's say in in a society
so I became a psychiatrist or medical
doctor I mean even then
as a medical doctor like there were
times in my life where I was kind of
thinking about well like is Psychiatry
like is that being a real doctor how
will I feel if I say I'm a neurosurgeon
which my my wife was like you should be
a neurosurgeon and like what does she
care she wants to introduce her husband
who's a neurosurgeon and I was like well
I've decided to do something close
it's in the same ballpark but it's a
little bit different
so we all crave the approval of other
human beings and now social media
quantifies that right
do people like me like normally the
human mind doesn't really know like
there's no way to measure it right you
sort of feel it but now I get 100 likes
and someone else gets 200.
and so what social media really does is
captures a lot of that identity-focused
kind of people who are concerned about
being something self-esteem now we have
filters which sort of fix the problem
and make the problem worse which is
oftentimes what we see in in social
media so the more that I use filters
the better I feel about my presence on
the internet but each time I use a
filter
I'm not accepting the way that I look in
real life
and so it'll make the problem worse
which is why I think we see some of a
lot of this like extreme filter using
usage that almost
doesn't you know seems like it isn't
real and people can kind of tell why do
people do that I think it's because they
kind of go down this rabbit hole
the comparison between are you having
fun now
and are you still using the technology
now it's so interesting because you know
I think about when I do get stuck Doom
scrolling through something and if I was
to ask myself that question you know
after 15 minutes probably or 20 minutes
on any social media I'm no longer having
fun
I spoke to huberman about this and I
thought this was a very interesting
reframe I'd love to get your thoughts on
this he sees social media usage more as
a compulsion than an addiction
in your opinion is there a meaningful
difference between the two do you
believe that this is the case does it
even matter whether it's the case or not
well I mean what what do you what how
are you defining the word compulsion
he said that it was more like a
compulsive action to pull the phone out
to look at it and to scroll to cycle
through all of the apps because I can't
remember his definition of addiction I
want to say it is uh
continuing to use a stimulus long after
the satisfactory nature of the stimulus
has been completed something like that
I'm going to guess that you'll know the
definition that I'm using yeah so let's
let's talk let's define things okay
so let's start by defining what is an
addiction
so the features of an addiction first of
all is that it impairs function so it
causes you some kind of damage
and the problem with addictions is that
there are solutions that fix a
short-term problem but damage things
long term
so if we look at a lot of features of
addiction like let's say I'm addicted to
opiates and what opiates do is they make
me feel good temporarily but they cause
me problems because let's say I'm
stressed about work and I use an opiate
or I use marijuana or something like
that my stress goes away
but
it doesn't fix any of my problems and if
I let's say get high today and then I
don't work on this project or whatever
like I I have one less day to work on it
so an addiction is is usually a behavior
that we engage in that despite the
damage that it does to us we continue to
engage in it now why do we engage in
addictions usually it's because they
provide some kind of relief or reward
and if we look at social media and video
games they're sort of very similar to
addictions in the sense that they
suppress negative emotional circuitry
which by the way is why it's more than
dopamine so even if you play a game for
eight hours let's say I'm ruining my
life and this is an experience that I
had firsthand right was failing out of
college and like how could I forget
failing out of college I could play
video games so it's not even the game is
fun at eight or nine hours but that
suppression of the amygdala and the
limbic system is like kind of there so
we know that a lot of what makes video
games addictive is like the fact that
they
push problems away temporarily which is
very similar to all these other
substances like if I get drunk right I'm
not worried about anything
so in that way you know that's what an
addiction is
now a compulsion at least the the
technical term of like a clinical term
right so if we're talking about
obsessive compulsive disorder
in that way a compulsion is usually a
behavior that we engage in that has some
kind of effect on our cognition
so so it like it I have to do something
to make me feel a particular way
and what I would say is there's
absolutely like a habitual that's maybe
what I would use there's absolutely a
habitual or a conditioning aspect to
technology usage which they're very good
at and I don't know if you've ever had
this experience but this happens to me
all the time where I will realize that I
am not liking what I'm using like a
particular device for and then what I'll
do is close the app and then open it
right up again
so we are absolutely being conditioned
but this is also where if you kind of
look at it the circuitry is a little bit
different there's habit circuitry
there's dopamine reward circuitry
there's like suppressing our amygdala
and all of that stuff is active when it
comes to technology usage so I think
it's kind of like all of you above we'll
get back to talking to Dr K one minute
but first I need to tell you about
element I've taken element every single
morning for probably three years now it
is my favorite way to start the day it
tastes fantastic it optimizes my
hydration it makes my brain work more
effectively and it really wakes me up
element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium with no gluten no colors
no artificial ingredients no fillers and
no BS they are the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
relied on by tons of FBI sniper teams
Special Forces Navy Seals and high
performers all around the world it plays
a critical role in reducing muscle
cramps and fatigue whilst optimizing
brain health and regulating your
appetite on top of all of that they've
got a no BS no questions asked refund
policy so you can buy it and if you do
not like it for any reason they will
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink lmnt.com modernwisdom to get a
free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom presumably that's what
makes it so powerful the fact that you
have all of these different networks all
coming together into this perfect uh
blend yeah absolutely and why is it
coming together so so profoundly it's
really interesting because there's like
there's almost this darwinian slug match
going on right now between platforms
so if you look at like Tick Tock versus
YouTube shorts versus Instagram reels
versus
whatever Google's going to come up with
at some point or I guess they've got
YouTube shorts
um you know so what are all these
platforms doing they're actually
competing for your attention
the prize that they get is like your
mind
and so like whether Google wins Tick
Tock wins or Amazon wins or whoever wins
the one guaranteed thing is that there's
definitely going to be one loser and
that's actually you you are going to
lose control of your mind which is
exactly what happens
and even then I don't think the
platforms are evil I mean maybe they are
but that hasn't been my experience I
think it's just they have a product
right and everyone wants their eyes on
their product
and so what they're figuring out is how
can I engage people by tapping into a
different you know Circuit of the brain
how can I help condition someone to use
my app so it's not just about dopamine
it's not just about it's emotional
engagement it's dopamine it's habit
formation all that kind of stuff
even pings and notifications they're
good at that given that we are
hopelessly outgunned up against billion
dollar companies with machine learning
algorithms some of which are the most
powerful ever designed in human history
and an entire team of software Engineers
behind every single button press
how can people set healthy boundaries
around gaming and social media
so I think thankfully we've we've got
a lot of good answers so I think this is
where prior to going to medical school I
spent seven years studying to become a
monk and the cool thing is that like
what the monks if you look at sort of
the Hindu and Buddhist traditions and
like meditation and mindfulness they
really figured out like how the mind
works and in a different way from like
the West so in the west we sort of
looked at a thousand different minds and
we sort of said okay if we average them
all together like what floats to the
surface but in the East they had sample
sizes of one so they're like okay how
can I understand where my desires come
from how can I get control of my desires
a lot of that stuff is kind of baked in
and what I actually find is the most
effective is starting with some of those
principles
so understanding first of all that all
of Technology really causes one problem
causes you to lose awareness
so anytime you get sucked in and in fact
this is why we want to use technology
right I want to go into a video game and
I want to get sucked into the video game
I want to binge watch shows so if you
look at like HBO and Netflix or whatever
right there they like really want us to
binge watch and we love binge watching
so if you look at the common element to
all these things it's a loss of
awareness
so the more that we can cultivate
awareness of things
the better off will be
and there's there's good evidence from
this from the world of Psychiatry as
well so if you look at like addiction
Psychiatry what we find is that if you
ask someone who relapses they'll say
yeah I was sober for six months and then
I don't know what happened
I just relapsed but what you really
discover and we sort of see this is that
people who are vulnerable to addiction
have a lack of awareness of their
internal emotional state and as
emotional stressors rise and rise and
Rise they like reach a particular
threshold that causes them to relapse so
a big part of what we do clinically when
we work with people is just raising
awareness
and so I'd say the first thing if you
want to set up healthy boundaries like
be aware of yourself why do you reach it
for it in the first place like are there
particular times of the day that you
reach for it
stuff like that
is there an emotional state that you
find yourself in that causes you to get
your phone out or to open up social
media on your laptop or to start
watching Netflix or to start playing a
video game absolutely so a simple
example of this is like if you think
about 30 years ago if I was trying to
study I would get distracted right I
wouldn't be able to focus on the
textbook and that's okay I would get
distracted for like a couple minutes I'm
sitting in a library I don't go anywhere
I don't do anything my mind wanders I
lose five minutes I lose 10 minutes and
then I come back to the text I'm like
all right time to get back to work now
what happens is even a 30 second
distraction I'm studying I pull out my
phone and I click a button and then my
mind is sucked into this like you know
pipeline of like attention grabbing
behavior and five minutes becomes three
hours
and so even a you know 30 second
attentional lapse now costs me an hour
of time
okay does that mean therefore that we
just need or the most robust solution to
stop yourself from using computers and
social media is to go places where you
don't have your phone and you don't have
video games is that the is that the most
robust tactic well so I mean I think
it's kind of like a lot of different
things right so we we
um I think it's first of all cultivating
more awareness of of the present and how
you feel and what your triggers are and
then at the other end they're absolutely
environmental aspects so one thing that
you know I'll tell people is that if
you're trying to get work done it's a
good idea to silence your phone or even
move it to the next room
um I I I'll tell people also like for
example if I'm working with patients who
are having trouble with sleeping at
night
to tell them hey keep your phone like at
the opposite end of the room or even
outside of your room and then everyone
sort of asks me like but what if there's
an emergency what if I get a phone call
in the middle of the night and then I
turn around and I ask them how many
times have you gotten a call in the last
two years that someone has needed your
help within five minutes
right and the answer is almost always
zero unless I'm working with a doctor in
which case like you know we have pagers
still
um so I think they're absolutely kind of
conditioning things or environmental
things that you can do using grayscale
being really aggressive with
notifications
um but also like the physical location
of your phone
and this is the other thing that that
platform developers are really good in
getting good at so if you think about
biometrics
the thing about Biometrics and face ID
is it actually reduces the time to
access your phone
so now even like the three seconds that
it used to take or two seconds to put in
your code now you just have to pick it
up and it it knows it's even that
friction has been removed yep that's
what they're doing removing all the
friction
okay so we have understanding your
triggers understanding the mental states
that you get into the emotional states
that you're in
um whether it's been a hard day at work
whether this is some sort of coping
mechanism because things are stressful
or you're just tired or whatever what
are the precursors that happen before
you then descend into using technology
in a way which
after the event you reflect on and wish
that you hadn't done there are some
environmental cues and factors that we
can use uh distance being one of them in
that you can't use a screen that you
can't put your hands on or see so
keeping it away sleeping with your phone
outside of the bedroom is there anything
else when it comes to good boundaries
what are the other longest levers yeah
so I think the other thing to consider
is that so we think about this as like a
problem that has a solution we don't
think about boundaries as skills that
are
built up right so if you think about
like a muscle like how do I lift more
weight I need to maybe do more weight
lifting
and if you kind of think about how do I
hold a boundary against a technology
that is becoming more and more invasive
you get stronger at holding boundaries
so what I'll do is I'll also give people
exercises and this largely comes from
the meditative tradition so you can like
formally sit down and meditate but
there's a lot of exercises that you can
develop based on the theory of
meditation my favorite thing to have
people do is no more phones in bathrooms
so like everyone takes their phone to
the bathroom now and if you just like
think about it like if I like say that
and people are listening to that the
instinctive reaction is going to be like
oh my God don't take that thing away but
like what are you gonna lose what am I
gonna do while I'm pooping Dr K you're
gonna do what human beings have done for
millions of years prior to the
development of Technology with the poop
just be with it so so what's happened in
our society as a whole is we have become
intolerant of boredom yes so if you want
to get control over every bit of
technology in your life you have to
learn how to not fear boredom and give
yourself small doses of boredom you know
don't take an audio book the next time
you go for a walk or don't listen to
music or something like that right and
and just start to like pick particular
discrete things don't watch things while
you eat
um so so there are all kinds of things
that you can sort of set kind of certain
lines and then really practice those and
then your mind will literally become
stronger so your ability to restrain
your attention and tolerate boredom will
increase is that something that you see
reflected neurologically
psychologically is this something that
actually shows up in the literature
somehow oh absolutely so so one simple
example in so many ways so let's talk
about literature in different ways so
the first thing is let's talk about
let's say psychological literature
so we know that for example people with
ADHD
have difficulty restraining their
impulses and they tend to get highly
distracted so we know that meditation
for example helps people with
impulsivity and improving Focus that we
kind of know if you sort of think about
it what is the practice of meditation
it's like literally practicing focusing
on a neurological level we know that
there are brain correlates with things
like ADHD like frontal lobe dysfunction
so the frontal lobes are Master Control
parts of the brain that they can sort of
restrain and direct our attention
and so what happens when we do things
like meditate or some of these practices
is that we learn how to like it
strengthens our frontal lobes and
there's even data that shows that it
strengthens sort of the inhibitory
circuits of the brain so our frontal
lobes can go and put the brakes on a
particular impulse
and then even if we're talking about old
old literature so we're talking about
the Sanskrit literature from like 5 000
years ago
there's this this one thing there's this
one principle called
which means focusing on one thing at a
time and thousands of years ago they
were like hey here's a technique to
focus on just one thing at a time and
you can kind of practice just doing one
thing at a time
and so there's a lot of scientific stuff
from everywhere from Clinical literature
to basic science literature to even like
old stuff
a lot of the work that I've done a lot
of the conversations that I've had
um
Adam Alta who wrote uh irresistible
um one of the ladies who is a lead
researcher and I want to say it's uh
cybernetics is that con computer brain
interfacing stuff like that but from a
psychological side and every single
person I've spoken to about attention
says people believe that they can
multitask first off you can't secondly
what you think that you mean by
multitasking isn't multitasking it's
parallel processing and you definitely
can't do that you can maybe task switch
and lose a ton of focus whilst task
switching but you definitely can't
parallel process you can do one thing
that you're focused on you can drive and
talk but you're not thinking about
driving you're passively driving
one of the things I've considered
throughout this conversation so far is
we've spoken about the fact that social
media and video games are very
compelling they cause people to be
um incredibly motivated to continue to
do them which can make the real world
less attractive
one of the solutions to that presumably
would be to take some of the principles
of video games and move them into the
real world to gamify some of the things
that you want yourself to do in the real
world
you may have read hardwiring Happiness
by Rick Hansen I I haven't good book
very very simple uh idea which is that
after you do something that you want to
do more of or that gives you in the real
world a uh little uh trigger of
happiness you go for a walk you complete
a workout today I managed to get my
email inbox down to zero I've got to
inbox zero and it's been in three
figures for months for [__] ages and
we are tempted to immediately just go
right brilliant that's done now on to
the next thing what have I got to do
next
his advice is to sit for about one to
two minutes and just allow yourself to
kind of
marinade in wow I I did a thing that was
good that was really good I completed
the workout I went for the walk I got up
on time I did the meditation I got my
morning routine I got rid of 120 emails
that's nice
and then you can go about your day so
his he comes from a neuroscience
background his argument and he was the
guy I'm pretty sure that kind uh neurons
that fire together wire together so if
you want to do more of a thing
allow yourself to feel the reward from
it yet we do I notice it in myself I
finally complete a task and it's it's
kind of like relief but it's almost like
bitter relief I'm like right thank God
that's done now on to the next thing you
go no no you've just earned this period
where you can sit and and be all
self-righteous and and up on a high
horse for at least a couple of minutes
uh so that's one tactic that I'm trying
to use a lot more at the moment which is
allowing myself to kind of genuinely
sit with a good experience and feel that
for more than a nanosecond
okay how's that working out for you
um I need to do it more but it is good
uh I've certainly been able to
make myself feel
more pleasure
in advance of completing something that
I usually don't want to do
so let's say that I am going to go and
do a hard workout or I'm gonna go do
zone two cardio right it's the most
boring thing in the world
I know that at the end of that I'm going
to feel good and because I've spent a
good bit of time sitting with that good
feeling it almost feels like I've
started to bring that feeling before I
begin to do it that I associate the
activity of doing something even though
it sucks and it's kind of boring because
I know at the end of it it's going to be
good I've managed to bring that feeling
from the end to the start which is
reduce the activation energy to go and
do the thing yeah so I think it's it's
really useful to try to do stuff like
that I think we see that a lot for
example with like practicing gratitude
where a lot of people will
skate over their wins and focus on their
L's I think a big thing that people
don't really realize is we're not wired
to do that
so if you kind of think about
you know people who sit and relax after
getting a w don't get to where you and I
are Chris the people who say I got to
inbox zero today good job what's next
that's what actually correlates with
like material success
right and I see this a lot because I've
worked with a lot of people who are like
very high functioning like entrepreneurs
like CEOs people in finance and medicine
and neurosurgeons and whatnot and it's
the people who drive themselves
relentlessly forward that actually
correlates with a lot of success which
is where this whole like Sigma grind set
kind of stuff comes from is right like
it's about grinding grinding grinding
grinding grinding and that's also where
we need to kind of take a step back and
really ask ourselves what is our brain
wired for
it's not wired for contentment it's
wired for survival
and so what what it's kind of
interesting right because you're working
so hard
to be like to be able to enjoy something
that you should do
and so it's kind of like you're in this
Relentless pursuit of like better
right so like okay I why do I need to
exercise to be better and now I'm not
happy with being better so what do I
need to do I need to get better at being
better I need to learn how to be better
and so it's kind of bizarre but
sometimes I'll see this with a lot of
the really successful people I work with
it's like now even happiness is
something that I need to grind towards
and I'm going to read books and I'm
going to understand Neuroscience but if
you really kind of take a step back it's
actually a manifestation of the same
thing you're going to grind your your
way to Enlightenment people even use the
rest and Recovery days as part of their
productivity oh well I'm going to take
I'm going to take this day off because
it means that tomorrow I can come back
harder and I can work even harder hang
on hang on a [__] second that that is
not that is not what a day off is
supposed to be a day off is not supposed
to be part of your productivity system
to allow you to come back to work harder
there's this really awesome example of
this and someone emailed me and said
that I got it right I thought I got it
wrong and this guy emailed you'd studied
Classics and told me that I got it right
in ancient Greece the ancient Greek word
for work translated as not at leisure so
work was seen as an aberration it was
something that you did when you weren't
doing the Leisure thing
roll the clock forward now Leisure is
the thing that facilitates work it's not
even the thing that you do when you're
not at work it's the thing which allows
you to do more work
I I think that that's I would tend to
agree right so I think that what we tend
to find is like if we look at
productivity having your internal values
having even like a cognitive fingerprint
that fits your work work quote unquote
lifestyle is like a huge part of
getting all of it so when I even think a
little bit about like my day so one of
the things that I found is that I tend
to get bored easily so rather than just
seeing patients over in my office like
over and over and over again day after
day year after year I do different stuff
throughout the day and so this doesn't
feel like work for me even though
technically it's work this is fun
and and I think this is a big challenge
that a lot of people face right now is
they're struggling with this sort of
idea of like they think about work and
Leisure is like two different things
and then this is why we see burnout
because as you said you know Leisure is
what allows you to work great but when
you don't have that
then you can grind and grind and grind
and you're gonna burn out and burnout is
like an epidemic level like levels right
now just in basically every field that
we're talking about we'll get back to
talking to Dr Kane one minute but first
I need to tell you about manscaped if
you're a gentleman who needs to trim his
sensitive areas and you are still using
an old face shaver from five Christmases
ago what are you doing join us here in
the modern world there are purpose-built
tools for the job and the manscape
lawnmower 4.0 is the greatest ball and
body hair trimmer ever created it
features a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents a 90 minute
battery which allows you to take a
longer shave or if you're just a
particularly hairy gentleman waterproof
technology which allows you to groom in
the shower and an LED light which
illuminates grooming areas for a closer
and more precise trim or if you just
want to do it at night perhaps it's also
got a wireless charging system to help
the battery last even longer but best of
all you can get 20 off everything
site-wide from manscaped and free
shipping if you go to manscaped.com
Modern wisdom and use the code modern
wisdom at checkout that's manscaped.com
modern wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout speaking of high performers
you've spoken to some of the world's
biggest streamers people like Pokemon
and xqc and Asthma gold most critical
etc etc Ludwig as well
what are some of the lessons that you've
learned from speaking to people who are
the most online
that they've they've won being online
they're the most online people on the
planet what have you learned from
speaking to them
um
wow so a couple of different things the
first is it's not nearly as fun or easy
as they make it look
so oftentimes and I've worked with a lot
of people so you know was in Boston for
a while and working with people out of
startups and stuff out of MIT and
Harvard and just really really hard
working people I work with people at
like Goldman Sachs and Google and and
whatnot and and like there are a lot of
people who work really hard I don't
think people really appreciate how hard
the people who are at the top are and I
don't think people really appreciate the
balance of skills that's necessary
to achieve that so it's some amount of
spontaneity and being able to have fun
on command so these are people who are
in the business of friendship and I
think the biggest thing that people
don't understand is the level of
sacrifice it takes to get there so what
we see is someone who's huge and
recognized and has all these sponsorship
deals and presumably has all this money
and things like that but the levels of
sacrifice because what they really have
to do is sacrifice just about every
dimension of their life
so what we sort of think about even when
I compare them to Bankers is like
bankers get to go to work and have their
professional relationships and they get
to go home and they get to have their
friends
but what we really see with streamers is
they sacrifice on every dimension
so your friends will invite you or not
invite you depending on what the collab
will get them
right and then if you turn some so like
even friendship becomes a part of your
job like the the other thing that I
think people don't really appreciate is
that
the human brain is not designed to deal
with criticism from millions of people
so if we think about like tribal
structures you know if I grew up in a
tribe of 300 people how often am I going
to get criticized
and we have these different biases that
people don't really think about which is
that even if 99 people tell me that they
like me if one person tells me that they
don't like me that's the thing that my
mind is gonna clue in on so now you take
these people who get millions of points
of feedback
and their brain is literally designed
and I've seen this as a streamer myself
where I can see tons of messages
scrolling past faster than I can read
them but my brain can pick out the one
thing that is actually damaging it
actually enters into my conscious
thought and this is where the brain is
processing all kinds of info information
that we're not aware of
and so I think people don't really get
how hard it is
and the beautiful thing is that the
people who are successful are the ones
who are able to find some kind of
balance
otherwise you just can't sustain it and
you're like you'll burn out and then
doesn't work so they're amazing
resilient individuals it's almost like a
battle of attrition
in that way absolutely and most people
don't can't make it to the Finish Line
it's like a marathon That Never Ends
there's a quote from Jason Park in one
of my favorites that says Your Heroes
aren't Gods they're just regular people
who probably got good at One Thing by
neglecting literally everything else
yeah I think that that's probably true I
I think but what I what I see at the
highest levels of performance is that
you usually have to be good at a lot of
things and you can't neglect too much
because it's going to come and catch up
with you eventually absolutely you know
your health will catch up with you yeah
but that's so there's a a guy in the UK
who is a weightlifting coach uh sorry a
powerlifting coach can't get that wrong
and one of my friends started working
with him he works with people for free
he's this Savant programmer unbelievably
smart but he's 78 or something sort of
old guy and he gets unbelievable results
for the athletes he works with he
doesn't charge anybody he's already made
his money he retires he works with
people on invite only and the
programming is ruthlessly hard what I
realized was he was getting around about
two to two and a half years of progress
within one year of programming but the
reason that he was doing this was
because he was absolutely battering his
athletes into the ground now what you
end up with is a scenario where the
athletes who end up Surviving this who
don't get injured who don't get burned
out who don't get too tired who don't
lose passion
obviously are going to have made
unbelievable progress because the
programming's brutal it's more volume
it's more frequent it's high weights
it's higher rpes
and survivability bias or survivorship
bias means that the only ones that do
make it to the End by virtue of the fact
they've made it to the end
have unbelievable progress what you
don't get to see are the attrition rate
it's how many people fell away what's
your churn how many people got injured
how many people gave up on their passion
and this is a lens I need to come up
with a name for it I need to meme this
this is a lens through which I see a lot
of very difficult Pursuits that
basically it it does come down to a
battle of attrition and if there is
somebody that can out suffer you if
there is someone for whom they can go
seven days without seeing sunlight but
you can only go half a day without
seeing sunlight
in some regards they have a competitive
advantage
yeah so I you know I I I'd Express a
little bit of
push back on that so I think that's a
commonly accepted View
that the people who sacrifice the most
get the most
but honestly Chris in my experience with
lots of people and even myself like so
you know I did pretty well in medical
school I didn't study over two hours a
day
like I had caught like I tried it for
the first month where everyone else was
like you know we're gonna go to class
and we're gonna say the library 10
o'clock at night 11 o'clock at night and
I was like I just can't do that so I
studied two hours a day and I did fine
and and I think that there's this idea
that
being successful requires sacrifice but
I think there's a huge selection bias
there usually the people who are talking
about the sacrifice they made to succeed
are like there's a selection bias there
the people who are like yeah it was
actually pretty easy for me you don't
actually hear from them
and so there's something almost like
psychological where I see that
you know if you succeed and you made a
sacrifice it's very psychologically
difficult to swallow that you didn't
need to make the sacrifice in the first
place
so oh wow it's it's really interesting
this is like data behind this too
so the way that people value what they
get correlates with the price that they
pay there's a study that was done I
don't remember exactly where I I'm
slipping on the reference but people
actually asked people who joined
fraternities in University
how good is your fraternity and what it
what a really interesting variable is
that the more the fraternity demeans you
the higher the value of the fraternity
even though by some objective measures
like some people have really good
connections but one of the worst
fraternities on campus people were like
this is the best fraternity and what was
their hazing process they stripped them
down naked tied them all to trees and
then were urinated on by other people
and when you go through that sacrifice
you can't psychologically say yeah I
didn't get anything for that I just
sacrificed a ton for nothing and I
didn't need to but look really the work
that I do with people is all about hey
actually you don't need to sacrifice
that much build a healthy balanced
lifestyle get yourself into the Flow
State more often and you can actually
achieve
just as much
by paying half the cost with nowhere
near as much suffering absolutely this
is a really really important Insight I
absolutely love it I love the reframe I
love everything about this I think as
well there is something around an
incentive or there is a disincentive for
people to talk about things not being
hard on the internet first off
if it wasn't difficult then that means
that it's less of a costly signal to you
so the achievement that you have is less
impressive secondly there is so much
more criticism on the internet for you
if it doesn't look like you had to go
through things oh easy for you to say
must be nice for you to say because if
somebody else does find it more
difficult or can't have theory of mind
to understand that it could be done just
through more of a flow state or less
grinding or whatever that means that
you're going to get criticized more
there's another uh lesson that I learned
when I was on Rogan's show and I memed
it into Rogan's value difficulty
conflation
look at the car he's driving look at the
watch he's wearing look at the girl he's
with that's unattainable to many people
so it seems like it's valuable but then
you attained it and you realized oh this
isn't valuable this is just difficult to
get and there's a difference there's a
big difference what's valuable is
something that fulfills you
intellectually emotionally spiritually
lovingly most smart people realize that
there is value in stepping outside of
their comfort and on the other side of
discomfort is something valuable we're
told that things are difficult to attain
because if they weren't that we're told
that worthwhile things are difficult to
attain because if they weren't difficult
to attain they wouldn't be worthwhile
and this is how non-valuable but
difficult things get slipped into our
desires without us noticing attaining
something worthwhile is often going to
be difficult but just because it's
difficult doesn't mean it's worthwhile
absolutely and I think the other thing
there is that you've got to also think
about the audience right so what
resonates with the audience what
resonates with the audience is hey if
something is hard for me
and you tell me it's super difficult and
you achieved that fits with my world
view so I'm gonna watch you
whereas if someone says hey this is
pretty easy
this guy is taking stuff for granted
just like you said I'm gonna click off
onto something else so there's
absolutely a selection bias towards
validating the difficult experiences
that most people have
I think the big irony is that oftentimes
and if you just think about something
that you've struggled with yourself
oftentimes once you figure it out it's
actually pretty easy
right but people kind of ignore that and
they just think that oh like
you know it's kind of bizarre but like
they just think like oh this stuff is
hard but once you figure out let's say
how to talk to girls like you just kind
of know and it's actually pretty easy
I suppose the uh the current trend of
Sigma grind set monk modes uh suffering
online as well plays into this
absolutely
right because people think like because
what do people want people want a
guaranteed way to get to the top they'll
pay a sacrifice if you can guarantee
success and that's why it's like Sigma
grind set you just sacrifice everything
you've got and then you'll get to the
top uh this is the same as the dude that
coaches people that look the the you are
either going to give up or you're going
to succeed because the level of effort
and discomfort that you're going through
is inevitably going to bear fruit at
some point in the future however the
cost may be your sanity and Health and
Longevity and and well-being along the
way
yeah I mean so I like
that's a perspective but I think
honestly like I love being a clinical
doctor because medicine teaches you some
really hard lessons and the top of which
is you can fight really hard and you can
still lose like I've seen people die of
cancer I've seen people you know and
that hasn't like
this is the thing that I think a lot of
people don't get is that sometimes
people are just gonna lose
like not everyone can succeed not
everyone can be a billionaire not
everyone and and you know it's kind of
bizarre but I think those people can
absolutely be helped they can absolutely
move forward
but I I think this sort of idea of like
you know you you can either give up or
you can succeed but my question is can
you succeed in like 10 of the time if
you do it smarter
how do you square the fact that even
people that try incredibly hard will
sometimes lose
with not wanting to disempower people
from uh or disincentivize people from
trying hard and from starting things
well if I try hard and I'm going to lose
what's the point in even starting
yeah so so my thought is first of all
don't try hard
can you try easy
so if you really look at it like most
things are most human beings who
struggle with something it's actually
like a gap in understanding
and and so like even in the ancient you
know Hindu and Buddhist texts they say
that avidya
which is ignorance is the cause of
suffering like if you just don't know
how stuff works right so like I had a
kid one of my kids the other day tried
to open a pill bottle like for her gummy
vitamins and there's just a technique to
open pill bottles and she can try as
hard as she wants to until she
understands the technique and once you
have the the technique it becomes easy
and there's even stuff with with things
like studying and things like that where
there's a certain there's a science of
spaced repetition there's a science of
concentration there's a science of like
health
right if we take particular things and
you facilitate your gut microbiome it's
like it's crazy I've had some patients
who have had inflammatory bowel disease
for like 15 20 years
and no one has ever talked to them about
like controlling their diet and and
supporting their their gut microbiome
and they'll like do this stuff so they
went through like six months of
treatment and then they're like they're
cured right they have no no symptoms now
and so I think the the biggest thing
that that human beings really struggle
with is not that like you need to try
harder and in fact I think that's it's
such a if you really think about I'm not
trying to throw shade on anyone but you
either give up or you succeed that can
be a really toxic mentality because if
you're doing things wrong
what is that person going to tell you to
do try harder
and if you're still doing it wrong try
harder try harder try harder right and
I've seen this once again I'm trying to
throw shade on anyone who's religious
but sometimes people are like yeah you
didn't pray hard enough
that's the reason it's not working
and so you you create a situation where
it's like an unfalsifiable hypothesis
that that creates a value judgment on
the person
that hey if this isn't working you gave
up
you're a loser there are quitters and
they're doers and you fall into one
category
and and the reason those things work is
because it's really validating because
that's how those people feel about
themselves in the first place which is
why they're listening to a life coach
because if they're happily married with
like two kids and like you know I mean
maybe they're sort of into the success
stuff and things like that but like a
lot of those people just don't listen
you know because they're out too busy
living their lives is there's a lot of
stuff going on here that we've just got
to be careful about
and sometimes I mean I'm not saying that
this stuff is bad we'll encourage people
to work hard and don't give up and stuff
like that and sometimes you gotta try
but I think there's like a differential
diagnosis here where it's not that you
know you didn't try hard enough is just
one of the reasons why things may not be
working out
I have a friend Aaron and every time
that we're in the gym he's very well
trained in movement uh and we were doing
holding some Copenhagen plank which for
me absolutely wrecks it wrecks my lower
body it wrecks my upper body and he
shouted from the other side of the room
what would this be like if it was easier
that was his cue his cue to me was
because your tense and everything's hard
and you're sweating and it hurts and I'm
Breathing heavily and [__] I hate this
position and [__] my adductors are so
weak and you just shouted from the other
side of the room what would this be like
if it was easier and I think that's a
cue in a question Greg McEwen talks
about it as well in his second book just
what what would it be like if it was
easier what would this challenge that
you're facing be like
if it was a little bit easier
I think that's a lovely cue and if you
kind of think about you know like
weightlifting right what's the point of
a spotter how much help how much energy
does a spotter actually provide when
you're on that last rep and you can't
push it any higher right and the spotter
just gives you like two fingers
just a tiny bit and that's honestly what
we've seen is that people don't need to
try a whole lot harder what they really
need is usually a tiny bit of help
I can't stop thinking about a video from
bro sign's life you know Don Mazzetti
he's like a comedian does YouTube stuff
this Channel's been around for forever
yeah and I've seen a little bit of a
stuff he did he did a breakdown of all
of the different gym archetypes I can't
stop seeing it that he basically
realized that uh Sigma Jim Bros he said
is Jim emo
that Sigma mail is a gym emo and I was
like oh my God I can no longer unsee
that um so coming back to what we spoke
about before we were talking about
dopamine what are your thoughts on
dopamine fasting is there any evidence
for this
um so I think that there is some
evidence for it I think some of it is
pretty good but the amount of bad
explanations out there are
really really high what's the landscape
of dopamine fasting then what's hot yeah
so the first the first thing is like
okay
you can't fast from dopamine dopamine is
a neurotransmitter okay so this is and
the other thing is like people I don't
think people get this but
you know Parkinson's disease is a
deficiency of dopamine it's the death of
dopamine neurons in your substantia
[__] you couldn't move you can't move
if you're out of dopamine
so we don't want to get rid of dopamine
dopamine's not bad it does all kinds of
stuff for us it's a neurotransmitter so
a neurotransmitter is just a chemical
signal it's like a letter of the
alphabet and people are like we're going
to remove the letter d and it's like
wait hold on that destroys a lot of
things besides dopamine right so so you
can't really fast from dopamine first of
all
secondly
I do think that there's a lot of good
healthy stuff that comes out of dopamine
fast so like I think it's useful right
so like taking a break from technology
is good for you in all manners of ways
but the whole point about technology is
you can't I I mean I actually wonder
about this there's some studies on
Naltrexone and stuff like that but I
don't think you can give someone a
dopamine blocker and like cure them of
their addiction you can do this a little
bit so there's some evidence that even
Naltrexone and some of these things that
interfere with dopamine signaling can
help with addictive behaviors but it's
not like uh one to one right so the
other thing that I think people really
need to understand is that technology
affects all kinds of other circuits in
your brain so the The Habit circuitry in
the brain is like governed just as much
by the endocannabinoids as it is by
dopamine
so I think that like a lot of the
science stuff is kind of crap
um I think that
if you implement some kind of dopamine
restriction which usually means
technology like I don't think people are
sort of saying like you can't have
dopamine like stop laughing right and
don't seem the most extreme version of
dopamine fasting where you're not
allowed to look at the people in the
eyes
I right so and this is the people that
here's here's your value difficulty
conflation conflation again right
because hey if it's harder it has to
work
and then you're also engendering so much
Placebo there because it's like wow I
like did this really thing and I must be
amazing now if I succeeded
but so I think a lot of the like the
scientific stuff is sort of BS
um and then the other thing to really
remember about the science is most of
the science is like extrapolated so so
it's you know like I said no one's
measuring dopamine concentrations in the
synaptic cleft and the nucleus accumbens
like no one's doing that everyone's
doing cross-sectional studies or
observational studies and so a lot of
what I base my stuff on is clinical
stuff which is also not really if you
think about it data right we work with
real human beings and the reason that we
need clinicians is because you can do a
scientific study about whatever you want
like you can do a cross-sectional study
but when it comes when it translates
over into like application with human
beings it becomes a lot more complicated
so generally speaking I think that a lot
of like technology restriction for
extended periods of time is probably
really good for you
um I think that there is uh probably a
lot of principles of like dopamine
tolerance and like we mentioned
anhedonian stuff I think the the data
behind that is pretty good so I think
the the biggest thing that restricting
yourself from technology does is
probably does help you reset that
tolerance sum
um and you know mixed bag about whether
people go through withdrawal or not so
you know some of it could be like more
of a real Neuroscience or physiologic
withdrawal but some of it may just be
like I'm used to not being bored in my
tolerance
for being bored is so low now because
that doesn't happen right we don't get
bored anymore everywhere we go we pack
you know I I remember seeing someone on
an airplane who was on an international
flight and they didn't bring anything
they just didn't break anything they
were there for eight hours and just
staring at the wall which by the way is
a great exercise that people in our
community do we tell them just stare at
a wall for an hour it's one of the most
powerful meditations that people in our
community do
what are the outcomes that someone that
looks at a wall for an hour get
men it spans the whole range of things
some people will like break down and cry
some people will have catharsis for some
people it'll be complete torture with no
benefit
it's like a whole thing
right but it's just learn to be bored
you see what the running a marathon was
hard stare at this wall for an hour yeah
I mean at least you've trained your
muscles to run the marathon have you
trained your mind to be bored for an
hour
and the beautiful thing about that is
once you can train your mind to tolerate
boredom you no longer fall into the pull
of these things
right because then you don't need to
play a video game because boredom's okay
what have you learned about porn use
amongst young men and how they feel
about it
so I think porn use is one of the most
misunderstood things from this is my
opinion okay from uh clinical
perspective from a psychological
perspective from a neuroscience
perspective
so
you know we've done a lot of work with
pornography usage pornography addicts so
I think the first thing to understand a
lot of interesting stuff came out from
our internal research we're hopefully
going to publish a paper on this within
the next year or so but hasn't really
been formulated yet
so the first thing that's really
interesting is that people who are
addicted to pornography oftentimes get
exposed at a very very young age we're
talking about first exposure to
pornography like pre-pubescent most of
the time
second thing is that pornography usage
has nothing to do with sexual perversion
so a lot of people think if someone is
really really addicted to pornography
they must be like really horny or like
depraved in some way or things like that
generally speaking my experience has
been that pornography usage is really
just a very powerful emotional coping
mechanism
so pornography usage will suppress a lot
of negative emotions and if you talk to
people who use pornography especially in
an addictive way what leads to usage is
like feeling bad about yourself and this
is the big problem with pornography
usage which is that once you start to
use it it sort of engenders more shame
and guilt in order to deal with the
shame and guilt you have to use it again
right and and it's just the kind of
thing where if you like think about the
societal stigma if someone's like yeah
you know like I grew up and and I was
addicted to alcohol like and now I'm
sober for 20 years and it's like good
for you man and it's like yeah I'm a
recovering pornography addict and it's
like
you know you're not going to get the
same you know if you're dating someone
and you're let's say you have a brother
or sister like yeah I'm dating someone
who's like been sober for 10 years like
cool right like that's probably good
like not bad for you like I'm dating
someone who's like been addicted to
pornography for 10 years and they're
they're you know like
there's a lot of stigma associated with
a lot of Shame associated with it I
think it's really about emotional
regulation
this is really interesting there's
research that shows that
um so it really has nothing to do with
sex basically which is what's weird I
mean it can have sexual consequences and
stuff and create problems in
relationships but there's a research
that did a multivariate regression
analysis on people addicted to
pornography which means they looked at
which variable Associates the most with
pornography usage and the number one
variable was meaninglessness
so the more meaningless your life is the
more likely you are to be addicted to
pornography
and so what we've actually kind of found
which is really interesting is when you
work with people like that helping them
develop like purpose helps them actually
like you have to have a reason to stop
watching pornography it's got to be like
some kind of you know
you have to go through that withdrawal
for some greater good and so helping
people find purpose is like one of the
biggest things that apparently helps
with pornography
what do you think it says that porn use
doesn't seem to be
actually that massive of a sexual
trigger it doesn't seem to be triggered
all that much by it it's triggered by
things outside of
sex in a way it's triggered by life
circumstances meaninglessness yeah so so
I think it's this comes down to the
neurochemistry so if we think about
addictions
why do we get addicted to stuff because
of the effect it has on our brain
and so if we think about from an
evolutionary standpoint
there are a couple of different things
that will suppress our negative emotions
and will also give us like a rush of
like let's say euphoric
neurotransmitters so orgasm is one of
these things so why does orgasm feel
really good because it's required for
the procreation of the species right so
evolutionarily when orgasm feels really
good we're gonna have more sex and
that'll result in
the continuation of the human race the
interesting thing is if you look at
actually ancient yogic literature as
well they say that there's this you know
state of bliss called samadhi which is
sort of the purpose of meditation and
there are a couple of interesting ways
that you can get temporary samadhi and
orgasm is one of them so this also is
like one of the reasons that tantric sax
is a thing and and things like that
which is a maybe a conversation for a
different day maybe conversation for
today but I think we've known for a long
time so why is pornography like this
because orgasm has very specific
like activation within the brain and so
now if you kind of think about it let's
say I'm feeling worthless about myself
I'm not doing anything in life I'm kind
of like sitting around not doing
anything I'm tired of feeling this way
what is a switch I can flick in my brain
that lets me forget everything pushes my
negative emotions away and actually
gives me a spurt of
positive neurotransmitters which I'm not
sure exactly what happens when people
orgasm in the brain but you know and and
that's why pornography addiction exists
so it's not really about sex
that's so interesting that you have all
of these different coping mechanisms
whether it be binge eating whether it be
alcohol whether it be cannabis social
media video games porn what we what
we've done is
increase the variety of ways that you
can hide from your feelings
absolutely and pick pick your flavor of
ice cream for today
what is it gonna be yeah right and and
there's there are people have drugs of
choice which may be due to some amount
of genetic vulnerability but if you
really think about it I think about
pornography addiction is the closest to
substance use because if it's hard
hitting
like a fact right so if you think about
getting high there's discrete like
chemicals that enter into your brain and
like activate certain receptors whereas
video games are like a little bit more
Global but pornography is really
especially that arousal stuff and stuff
like that is a very targeted way to
activate your brain in a particular way
more closely resembles the substance
Downstream from pornography use have you
seen sexual dysfunction is this
Associated absolutely so okay so how is
it that porn use isn't all that sexual
and yet Downstream from porn use you get
sexual dysfunction for a couple
different reasons so first let's
understand that
sexual
means multiple things within one person
so there's a physical aspect to it
there's a neuroscientific aspect to it
there's a psychological aspect to it so
one thing that you tend to see is
something that you know a term that I
coined on stream one day death grip
syndrome
which is if you look at men especially
who masturbate when they use pornography
the physiologic
stimulus for lack of a better term
that men will use actually does not
approximate the
physiologic stimulus of intercourse
so to put it bluntly I'm trying to avoid
saying this but you know not using lube
and using your death grip hand feels
different from a vagina like that's just
how it works
and and so what happens is the the body
can acclimatize to this right like
that's like literally what happens so
you get used to you need a particular
kind of sim you get conditioned to
require a certain kind of stimulation to
achieve climax
and so then sometimes what can happen
when when people engage in sexual
intercourse is that they can't get that
kind of stimulus to achieve climax
they've de-trained themselves from being
stimulated by real physiological
interaction with somebody else's body
yeah absolutely right so they also have
a very very strong grip right so so
mentally and so there's interesting
things because I've literally worked
with patients where like the process of
this is deconditioning so we'll sort of
say like you know loose grip a lot of
Loop and and that'll be frustrating for
I'm serious I'm not I'm you know I know
it's funny but like seriously because
you have to do that physiological
deconditioning and you have to try to
approximate you know things like that
and there's all kinds of stuff that you
could do with your partner and things
like that too so you can fix this
sometimes you'll see like erectile
dysfunction just kind of straight up
um and then they're also like
neuroscience and psychological impacts
right so sometimes people will have so
much shame for pornography that there's
you know they have difficulty performing
they feel so guilty uh there's all kinds
of stuff like does your partner know
that you use pornography and things like
that so that can lead to
um you know a difficulty with sort of
forming and maintaining erections which
is different from reaching orgasm right
so there's a whole physiologic chain of
things going on
and and so we'll we'll definitely see
that kind of stuff and then in some
cases what you also tend to see is that
there's this principle called online
drift on the internet where
since the goal is emotional engagement
how does a platform keep you emotionally
engaged they do it by serving up more
extreme content so if you look at your
platform algorithms if there's certain
things that you search for it'll serve
you like tons of extreme stuff in that
way
so if you watch one cute cat video
then you need to see cats doing cuter
things to stay on the platform and then
cats are doing cuter stuff and cuter
stuff and cuter stuff we see this with
pornography usage as well where there's
like a gradual like movement towards
like hardcore pornography use because
you require
more stimulus to your eyes and ears and
things like that to get that same level
of arousal and if you do that and if you
require that really high level of
stimulus
of of you know just like more brighter
bigger whatever and and then if you if
you have sexual relations with a regular
human being like the stimulus is just
different
if you're not able to recreate the zero
gravity acrobatics that you've just seen
on Pawn Yeah Mary Harrington calls that
the law of FAP entropy which is whatever
you start out wanking to will get
progressively more intense over time
beautiful yeah it's it's her second law
of porno Dynamics I think actually
um I I really like the introduction of
the framing in the story that you tell
yourself around your Pawn use is
massively
contributing to what is going to happen
out the other side of it and I think
that again you know
um what would this be like if it was
easier
um what would there is a trend online at
the moment that demonizes pawn use and
it's because there is a non-zero number
of people for whom porn use is
destructive and can't control it that
has been used to cover all of ponies as
if you're using porn this makes you
susceptible to a a whole Suite of
problems that are going to occur even if
you do have a healthy relationship with
it because there are a whole host of
people that are able to use pawn and
have a healthy relationship with it and
at least not have dysfunction on the
other side of it whether it's healthy or
not maybe a little bit of a different
discussion
but for the people who see their Pawn
use as something which is worthy of
Shame which is worthy of guilt which is
worthy of making them feel like less of
a man less of a appropriate partner
I can guarantee that you are somebody
who does have a problem with porn use
porn news is not good for you if that is
the story that you tell yourself about
your Pawn use and it's so recursive and
and self-reinforcing it's brutal
yeah absolutely I mean I think that you
know it's interesting because when when
people sort of demonize porn use I think
I'm seeing this trend more and more
where
if something if I have a problem with
something our society is moving more and
more towards that thing needs to go away
as opposed to I need to get better at
handling it
and so the really scary cycle that I see
is that the more that we remove things
the less tolerant we become
and then smaller and smaller things can
set us off concept yep and it's really
bizarre because it's literally the exact
opposite of what we do in exposure
therapy right so when someone has a
phobia like we literally have a clinical
Intervention which has been
scientifically sort of like the standard
of care for phobias is exposure therapy
which is hey this thing bothers you and
we're going to expose you to a tiny tiny
amount of it until we can decondition
that physiologic response and then we're
going to go up and then we're going to
go up and we're going to go up until you
can tolerate it but on the flip side
with and I think it's okay to cancel
some people I'm not like against cancer
culture but I think it's important to
understand what are the consequences of
cancel culture and how can we sort of
buffer against those we need to train
ourselves to be able to handle difficult
stuff a little bit better
I even saw a meta-analysis recently that
offering trigger warnings actually
increases anxiety and doesn't actually
help people in any sort of way yeah yeah
if you snowplow out of the way anything
that could be even mildly objectionable
to people what you do it
you don't change the fact that people
are going to find things offensive what
you do is you adjust the level at which
their offense begins people are going to
find and this is you know one of my
great friends Gwenda Bogle he speaks
about the fact that
um there is a community of people out
there for whom finding racism in the
world is their job it is their job to go
out there whether this be due to status
due to speaking gigs and engagements
writing books
their level of racism the amount of
racism that they find is going to stay
constant if racism decreases
that means that they need to find more
and more things to be racist in order to
maintain there is a supply and demand
problem with regards to racism and if
the supply of racism decreases or the
supply of anything decreases offense
objectionable content whatever it is
there are some people out there who are
just going to adjust themselves down the
whatever the price demand curve to find
more and more things that
yeah and I think you know if if you're
on a crusade let's say and I think
there's like a good reason to do that
right let's let's say that I'm against
you know
I don't know like sexual assault and
even if I make sexual assault 50 better
my work isn't done right like and so I
think there are good reasons to do that
sort of thing but what what kind of
bothers me and this is when I like
literally when I work with patients and
stuff right who have narcissistic or
abusive parents or siblings or things
like that
and and we sort of talk a little bit
about okay this person says these words
right but like really the goal when I
work with patients is how can you let
their words no longer control you that's
like the point of therapy when someone
has had an abusive parent right you get
to it it's not easy but over time you
can develop the resilience and fortitude
to kind of acknowledge that hey like
even though this person is upset with me
they're upset with me I don't have to
take that in or I can learn how to set a
boundary around it I can draw a line I
can understand even in the best cases
that my parent was abused which is why
they learned how to talk about this
stuff and I can have compassion towards
them that's like literally what we try
to do in therapy and then on a
macroscopic level we're almost moving in
the opposite direction
where we're sort of training ourselves
to be like mentally less tolerant and
I'm not saying that that's the solution
like I don't think we should I think we
should be mentally more tolerant but if
people are doing bad things we should
absolutely hold them accountable so
someone is out there spewing racist BS
there should be consequences for that
and at the same time I can enact those
consequences without being mentally
Disturbed which is a big part of what
being a psychiatrist is if someone
assaults me I can enact a consequence
about them and still go home I'm talking
about in the scheme of work right so if
you're working in the emergency room
someone's high on cocaine and they like
lash out at you like sometimes you
psychiatric professionals get assaulted
a lot at work
and so we can still hold them
accountable
and change the system things like that
but we don't have to be as upset about
it and there's actually training
involved there
that's a perfect conception going back
to one of the first things that you said
one of the best predictors for
pathological porn use is the age at
which you first become exposed to it
why how does porn use impact a
developing brain what is it about this
which direction is the arrow of
causation going in yeah so so a couple
of caveats about that so that's like a
observation we've made of people in our
community I don't know if there's
actually research on that but I wouldn't
be surprised if there was yeah that's
true of all the other addictions okay so
we sort of know why and so we know that
when you have a developing brain adding
a substance to it makes us more
vulnerable to it long term so there's
even studies that show that early
marijuana usage
leads is more likely to lead to
addictions of other kinds and it's
because when you use marijuana at a
young age it actually Alters how your
dopamine circuitry is formed
and leaves you vulnerable to other
addictions so my guess is that
pornography has some similar
neuroscientific mechanism where
something is going on where even if
you're because these people are
prepubescent usually when they're
exposed which means that they don't get
aroused
like usually right so so and they don't
even understand what they're seeing
which is the most common thing when I
talk to people who are addicted to
pornography most common thing is I was
like seven
and my 15 year old brother like showed
me this thing and him and his friends
were watching it and it was super cool I
didn't understand what was going on
but we do know that adding stuff to the
developing brain whether it's a
particular kind of stimulus let's say
like abuse of parents right so that's
not a substance or a substance Alters
its formation
and that those effects are
let's say not quite permanent but sticky
and then requires some time to be
rewired and so probably it has something
to do with the way that our dopamine
circuitry our emotional circuitry
those things kind of get laid down with
that perfectly shows why porn use is at
least in part not sexual
because you have you have this coping
mechanism for an individual who is as
yet not sexual
and and that I think is the the weirdest
thing for pornography addiction is that
like a lot of it honestly in my clinical
experience is like not very sexual in
nature it's really about some weird
emotional suppression you know mentally
checking out getting that Spurt of
relief
um and and that's also why you'll you'll
see so much usage it's not like people
are they feel compulsions as opposed to
feeling horny yeah which is not aroused
for eight hours straight right it's not
like you know we're gonna
jerk off all day and it's gonna be great
it's like I feel terrible about myself I
don't know what to do I feel a
compulsion to watch the stuff do this
thing for a while if I get into a fight
I need to do it again I'm
procrastinating I've wasted the whole
day I feel ashamed of myself because
I've done this for the last four hours I
need to do it again that's honestly more
of what it is
I think that taking it out of the realm
of sex which you know the world still
has massive problems talking about
openly it's something that's kind of
very shameful and guilt-ridden and
private and all the rest of it taking it
out of that and just saying black man
for you it's fapping for the girl that
lives next door it's binge eating the
guy that lives down the street it's
video games for the dude that lives next
door to you it's marijuana
coping mechanisms all the way down yeah
I think that takes away a lot of the
shame which is pretty cool one of the
other
um considerations that I imagine must
happen an awful lot is around bedtime
routines sleep sleep hygiene generally
from your community if you're talking
about people that use screens an awful
lot people that use social media porn
Video Games
Etc why is it
that we get so motivated in the middle
of the night instead of first thing in
the morning why did nature decide that
he was going to curse us so that our
brains can't shut off when we're about
to go to sleep and yet when we want to
wake up first thing in the morning our
brains don't want to start
so I think there are a lot of different
answers to this
um I think a big part of it is that
so a big part of what we do if we look
at the staring at a wall exercise for
example
so a lot of that real solid positive
motivation comes from within
and if we really look at our society
what's going on right now is we are
being told what we want all the time so
we've lost touch with ourselves right so
like there's a notification oh this game
is coming out there's this new movie
coming out there's a Super Mario movie
there's this movie there's that movie
there's this kind of thing and by the
way there's this kind of thing that you
can do to be healthy you should be
healthy you need to be healthy you need
to be more motivated this is how you
grind this is how you be productive be
all of these things
and so what's happening in our society
is we are gravitating
towards stuff outside of us all the time
and the people are getting better and
better at getting us get getting us
gravitated towards them right so Oreo is
figuring out okay what color can we put
the package you know how can we make it
crinkly like so that you know there's
some kind of pavlovian condition like
everyone's getting better at this
and so oftentimes if you kind of think
about it at night a couple of things
happen the night is the only time you're
with yourself
right and maybe you're and and I
guarantee you the people who are getting
motivated are not sitting there Doom
scrolling on their phone until they pass
out they're usually like sitting down
quietly or something like that like what
happens is you doom scroll you doom
scroll you do scroll you get tired you
put the phone away you put your head on
the pillow you don't fall asleep and
then you start having all these ideas
so it's really the only time that in the
shower right because we haven't we don't
have
we don't have waterproof phones
perfectly yet
so that's why like all these profound
thoughts happen in the shower it's not
like the shower is magical and has some
neurochemical that you're inhaling that
makes you more creative it's the only
time that you have with yourself
and there are studies that show that
meditation improves creativity and
things like that why is that it's
because you're with yourself
so that's one reason
there are a couple of other reasons
though I think that some people have a
different circadian rhythm and their
creative time is really late at night if
you look at basically religions across
the world they sort of have this
convergent evolution of mental work it
like
three to six in the morning so depending
on how late you stay up you may actually
be tapping into that what's in Sanskrit
called Brahma murta is also the time of
like matins so there's like this window
of time that based on circadian rhythm
where your mind is actually very very
active and that's how I ended up
studying two hours in med school I just
studied during Brahma work I was like
Hey and everything just sinks in
it's like getting up we're getting up
early or staying at play so we're
getting up early
so I'd wake up at like 4 a.m I'd do like
yoga and meditation I'd study for two
hours and I'd go to class and then I'd
Finish class and I'm done for the day
which is great
um so so I I think that you know you
have to be a little bit careful about
your circadian rhythm that just could be
your time but a lot of it is just that's
the time that you're with yourself
and so gotta just spend more time with
yourself like you're a cool person
you don't need something else to
entertain you
what about if people are constantly
dealing with brain fog this is something
that a bunch of people that I've worked
with over the years have complained
about that throughout the day their
thoughts always feel a little bit
muddled I
get the sense that this will probably
correlate with people who are also
sleeping quite poorly they're also
probably using phones late at night but
what is brain fog have you ever looked
at this clinically oh yeah a ton so so
uh uh we had a YouTube video about this
that that
went really well so I I think the the
tricky thing about brain fog is
as a clinician like we see it Frontline
and people don't really know what to do
so this is where so it's interesting I'm
I'm I mean I guess at this point I'm an
expert in in technology usage but my
actual like
historic expertise is an evidence-based
complementary and alternative medicine
and and so what we're really seeing when
in brain fog first of all I think we've
got to understand that your brain exists
within a body
so and we're seeing this more with like
gut microbiome research and things like
that but for the longest time at least
in eastern medicine
they didn't separate out mental health
from other forms of things like it's all
one thing right because the brain is
connected to the body so I think what we
we're also seeing a lot of brain fog is
a symptom of long covid so that further
um
demonstrates the kind of like
immune autoimmune inflammation based
results of brain fog so I think that
brain fog in my opinion is really
probably some kind of low level
inflammation that is going on so usually
when I'm trying to help people with
brain fog it's kind of weird but it's
not much psychological stuff like I
don't think it's like problems with your
emotions or Psychotherapy it's usually
more physiologic stuff so
anti-inflammatory diet even when it
comes to stuff like sleep I think a lot
of people don't realize that you know
especially if you use like marijuana or
like Edibles or CBD to help you sleep it
affects your REM Cycles it affects your
you know sleep stage architecture and
things like that
so a lot of times people will use things
to fall asleep
but don't really recognize or
acknowledge that the quality of sleep
that they're getting is pretty low
I have a kind of a personal Theory which
I've implemented with a couple of
patients which you know none of this is
medical advice but uh you know I've
tried using and when you talk to
patients you have to consent them
appropriately and stuff right so I'll
teach them which is a headstand which
seems to help with everything else
so even in potentially increasing blood
flow to the brain could help but but I
think really sort of focusing on
anti-inflammatory measures turmeric
things like that can can really help
people with brain fog do you know what's
happening with brain fog what what is it
like what what's going on inside of the
brain so my guess is that there's just
low levels of inflammation and or and
that sort of correlates with immune
activation within the brain and it could
be coming from other places too and the
felt sense of that is slower thoughts
yeah infusion less Clarity less
Precision Etc right so if you look at it
the first thing that we sort of know if
we review our you know neuroanatomy and
stroke architecture is that we know that
certain psychological and physiologic
problems are focal so that's one part of
the brain but with brain fog everything
is messed up a small to medium to even
severe amount so it's a global effect so
what kind of if we're talking about
global effects the sources are probably
going to be stuff like inflammation or
hormones or things like that stuff that
affects all of your brain and so I think
a lot of that stuff also with the covid
it sort of suggests that there's some
kind of
ongoing immune reaction or even
hopefully not damaged which I don't
think we really see with covid in the
brain you can you can get strokes and
stuff but
that's more clotting stuff but you know
so I I think it's probably low level of
inflammation is my best guess
one of my friends has just started
working with a new
glucose monitor company and when you get
your always on glucose monitor and you
put it on the back of your arm
it comes with uh I think four muffins so
you get it delivered you get glucose
monitor and with your glucose monitor
are four huge super sugary high calorie
muffins and on one of the days that you
don't have anything to do in the morning
you have to wake up and immediately upon
waking you eat two of these muffins and
you track what's happening are you
watching your your glucose shoot up
through the ceiling but you're not
allowed to train you're not allowed to
eat anything else you can't exercise you
can't do stuff to to try and get that
off and the lesson to learn apparently
from this apart from the fact it's how
does your body respond to glucose how
quickly is it able to clear it whilst
it's not training whilst it doesn't have
other things etc etc is also the felt
sense of this is what tons of sugar in
your bloodstream feels like and then for
lunch you have another muffin so you've
had two for breakfast and then you have
another one for lunch and um again it's
just one of the most interesting things
Beyond this is how my body is able to
metabolize glucose and get it out of the
bloodstream and all this stuff that he
learned one of the other things was he
had a number that he was able to now
attach to his felt sense of what high
blood sugar felt like and everybody
knows if you've had a huge binge one
evening you end up having a ton of
cookies or something else and I can
sometimes feel it in my joints I can
sometimes feel it it's like throbbing my
entire body is throbbing because I'm
just so [__] inflamed and I wouldn't
say that I'm hypersensitive to this but
you know everyone can push it if you get
a bag of Haribo tank fastics in front of
you or something and you go I've just
eaten 100 grams of sugar there that's an
awful lot yeah I think something that
people don't really
appreciate is that we have symbiotic
bacteria
and the bacteria that grow in our gut so
a lot of people will like eat will take
probiotics every day whereas like I
think it's
science without understanding so if we
think about okay what determines the
bacteria in your gut it's what you feed
it
so some bacteria are able to digest
complex carbohydrates some bacteria are
able to digest simple carbohydrates the
ones that we've sort of learned are
friendly which trigger less of an immune
response or the bacteria that have been
in our guts for thousands tens of
thousands millions of years and those
are the ones that eat like root
vegetables they help us digest those
things and now what started to happen is
we see all this how does food cause
inflammation like we know that fast food
causes inflammation sugar causes
inflammation it's because when we when
we eat these kinds of foods it selects
for we're fertilizing another kind of
bacteria that normally doesn't belong
there because like Twinkie eating
bacteria did not were not symbiotic so
now our immune system is like hey this
guy this bacteria doesn't belong here
but those are the ones that we keep
feeding
and so a lot of this inflammation that
we're kind of seeing I've seen a lot of
stuff around gluten recently where
there's a guy in Austin actually who
uses the strain of gluten that's like
800 years old doesn't trigger Celiac
problems for people and things like that
no way yeah
and that's cool it's really interesting
right so there's no scientific studies
on it yet but I think we're really
starting to see that a lot of this stuff
like diet and things like that which is
usually how we manage brain fog I myself
had really bad brain fog after covid and
went through this whole ayurvedic
regimen and was back to normal
and so it was it was you know I think
that we really inflammation oriented
you've mentioned a good bit today about
good microbiome and the relationship
between mood body General Health and
what's going on not just in terms of
eating diet but microbiome too
let's say that somebody hasn't ever been
introduced to the concept of microbiome
and how the food that they eat interacts
with that
where would you start somebody who says
I think that I might be suffering with
some brain fog I think that my energy
levels should be a little bit improved
what would you eliminate first what
would you try and add in first this is
not medical advice
yeah so I think the first thing to
understand is that if you're
so there are meta-analyzes that have
been done on diet
and basically what we know is that all
of the healthy diets
share a couple of things high amount of
fiber high amount of fruit like fresh
fruits and vegetables a certain amount
of protein and then ideally healthy
carbohydrates
now for any individual person some
combination of that may be like better
for you so like low carb intermittent
fasting like whatever but if you look at
meta-analyzes that compare all these
things that different people are doing
that's kind of what it comes down to so
the first thing to understand about gut
microbiome if you've got brain fog or
anything else
is that
in order for your brain to function it
needs nutrients
the nutrients that you get are
not just about what you eat but about
how you digest and how you metabolize
so there are two bacteria for example if
you look at people who have mood
disorders there are two bacteria that
are low in people who have mood
disorders if you look at people who do
not have mood disorders there are two
bacteria that are high
so what do we know so if I'm I'm a
medical doctor and if a patient comes to
my office with depression I can
prescribe an SSRI a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor boost the level of
serotonin in their brain in their
synaptic cleft
now the cool thing is that where does
our body's serotonin come from it's made
from tryptophan which is created by a
gut bacteria when we eat particular
kinds of food so there's some gut
bacteria that give us tryptophan
serotonin precursors
and what I've found as a clinician is
that when people follow the right diet
recommendations I can pull them off of
their SSRI within a year
but when they don't follow the diet
recommendations they need to stay on the
SSRI this has just been clinical
experience
so you really have to understand that if
you want your brain and body to function
correctly you need to feed at the right
kind of nutrients and it's not just the
nutrients themselves it's the fact that
half of your nutrient processing comes
from the bacteria in the gut and so it's
almost like you're creating a garden
that is going to give your body
nutrients
even this I cannot make this stuff up
there's a kind of bacteria called
ruminococcus
which is associated with anxiety I think
it's inversely correlated so people have
low levels of rheuminococcus have higher
levels of anxiety
and they've even done stool transplants
which is like when you take poop from
one human being and you put it in
another human being
and it will improve mood disorders I
have a friend who lives here in Austin
who is a stool donor for that precise
reason so he had to go through three
layers of
qualification
rigorous testing lifestyle questionnaire
phone interview tons of insights around
tracking food and stool sampling and
stuff
and he is now
selling his poop he is now a poop
Creator your friend shits gold literally
did we mentioned this when we saw him
it's like dude yeah you've managed to
monetize the one thing that everybody
could make a business out of
yeah some high quality poop you got
there I've said it as well yeah it's
like do you do any for free can I get a
mate's right discount
um yeah it's fascinating okay so that's
that's what's going on inside of us uh
foods that people should be more aware
of foods that you've found in your
clinical practice that uh people tend to
be deficient in okay so this is where we
got to take a step back and understand
digestion so before I went to med school
I studied Eastern medicine for a few
years and a couple of things that I took
away from there which I believe and I
think we're moving towards is there's
not a food that is good for a condition
the people's digestion is different
people's absorption is different and so
certain foods work for certain people so
even when I'm working with patients with
depression if I'm trying to get them off
of an SSRI
I will give them different diets
depending on what their like
Constitution is and like what their gut
microbiome is doing so I think that this
is where unfortunately like I wish I
could say eat these three things because
that's what people do now now they're
like okay what are the three things that
I need to eat but if I got to be
straight with you
that is the problem with
population-based medicine so when people
come and they say you should eat these
three things what do they do they look
at 10 000 people and they say okay on
average these three foods help ten
thousand people but if you really look
at that those three foods don't help a
third does it matter variance in there
yeah they don't help they help a little
bit in the middle and there's a third of
people that they help a lot with
so if you look at population based
medicine if we did if we sort of said
okay what should you wear we're going to
average together what everyone wears so
everyone the right thing to wear is like
a gray smoke
right that's not how it works so I think
one of the biggest things the things
that we really need to understand about
recommendations is that recommendations
really should be personalized and that
different people may need to eat
different things so if you've got an
anxiety disorder like you need more
ruminococcus or less I'm forgetting if
it's directly correlated or inversely
correlated and there are certain foods
that ruminococcus can be found in
but at the end of the day like
everyone's looking for like a oh just
eat these three things whereas I'd say
unfortunately it's like and this is why
we sort of find the meta-analysis shows
healthy fruits and vegetables complex
carbohydrates and like you know low
processed foods is the most important
thing
okay someone does that
does that mean in your view then that it
is important for people to cycle through
a bunch of different food different
foods different diets based on those
principles so we have some things that
are likely to be unchanging there will
be different flavors and versions and
whatnot on top of that absolutely so so
I think that just eating healthy doesn't
work ideally for like half the
population
so that's where you really need to learn
and make you know I think this is a
topic of a whole other conversation but
if you look at sort of the ayurvedic
system of diagnosis the Chinese system
of diagnosis what they do is they'll
diagnose you as having like a particular
kind of Constitution and there are
certain foods that will balance out that
Constitution
and and that's stuff that you know when
I was struggling with brain fog I went
to the ayurvedic doctor that I see and I
was like hey I'm having this problem
it's a lot of what are you are you are
you a fire person
uh I am predominantly Wind and
secondarily Fire
interesting
so I like to say that my mind is like
the wind so I blow really hard in One
Direction and then I change directions
very easily so I struggle with
consistency even if you all are like
watching this so I use my hands a lot
when I move the veins on the back of my
hands are very visible
if you guys like kind of see that
um and so there are other features like
there's physiologic features and and
things like that that are kind of
correlated with this stuff one of my
friends wives is one of my friends my
friend's wife not one of my friend's
wives uh is a ayurvedic
um
teacher slash doctor and it was the
first time six months ago it was the
first time that I ever heard about the
classification for people in that way I
found it absolutely fascinating
yeah it's a little bit unfortunate that
I think the data behind ayurved is is
not the best so there were some initial
studies that show that it tightly
correlates with genetic like alleles and
things like that but some of that
research is you know I think they want
it to be true
um but but the the scientific validity
is not the best clinically you know I
use it myself and I think you all should
talk to your doctor about it if you want
to try stuff
one of the other I guess common themes
that we've spoken about today is purpose
you mentioned earlier on that it is a
prophylactic against uh certain
dysfunctions that people can encounter
why is finding purpose so difficult in
the modern world in your opinion
so I think it comes back to something
that we talked about like so purpose
really does come from within so people
can give you responsibilities but then
those become shoulds
and the beautiful thing about purpose is
that that's what makes
doing hard things easy
so everyone's out there trying to make
everything easier but
if we can easily do the hard thing then
life becomes very easy
so if you kind of think about okay like
I I worked 20 you know I'm I'm up for 18
hours of a shift I have six more hours
to go I want to go to sleep I don't want
to be here why do I keep doing it I do
it because I care about my patients I do
it because if I work a 24-hour shift I
get to see my kids more
so there's a three-year-old at home that
like unless I work these 24 hours like
we're not gonna make you know either I
work anyway so as a parent you make
sacrifices for a good reason so purpose
is what allows us to make sacrifices
and we're becoming a world that it's
becoming harder and harder to make
sacrifices in fact we want the opposite
we don't even want to sacrifice and
tolerate five minutes of boredom boredom
while we're taking a poop
you know I need that constant
dopaminergic stimulation and so the more
the less purpose we have in life and if
we think about you know people who are
fighting today in in Ukraine or like
people who like people who do difficult
things have a reason for it
and so now what's happening in society
is like people can't do hard stuff
because like why do you wake up in the
morning there's like an existential
nihilism like anti-work and wealth
inequality and climate change like
what's the point
and so you can take as many supplements
as you want to to boost your motivation
but if you don't have a reason to get up
in the morning like
this is something I learned as an
addiction psychiatrist you can't give
someone a reason to quit they have to
want to quit themselves you can't make
someone sober they have to want to do it
and so what makes purpose hard I think
it's because Society externalizes our
attention
so in nature
our attention is like halfway within us
and halfway directed towards the
external but now with notifications with
dopamine with with you know colors and
everything being bright and stuff we
don't we don't know what it is to be
ourselves we don't even know what we
want all we know about quote unquote
what we want is what we've been told to
want
and I'll see this a lot because I'll
advise people who want to go to med
school and I'll ask them why do you want
to go to med school and they give me
some BS answer about helping people and
they're like I want to help people and
it's like why don't you go work in a
soup kitchen you have to go to school
for four years for that and help people
today
they're like uh
uh and then it's like why do you want to
go to med school like I don't know you
want to do it for the prestige and the
money and to make your parents proud
let's be honest and they're like yeah
and then you can work from there right
okay so like that's not going to work
dude you're going to burn out
so I think why it's hard to find purpose
is literally this is more from a yogic
perspective but our attention is no
longer directed internally so what we
end up with is a life of shoulds
and where does it should come from a
should comes from the outside it comes
from the expectation of other people
and then our purpose actually comes from
within and so the more that we spend the
more our attention gets pulled into
things outside of us the more we lose
sight of like what we want
crowdsourcing your sense of self-worth
to the world around you is a Surefire
way to be miserable yeah absolutely and
directionless
okay but we are inevitably intertwined
with the world around us we are going to
be exposed to screens and expectations
and societal norms and social media and
what our parents wanted us to do and the
way that we've dealt with past traumas
and our fears of insufficiency and the
fact that Sigma grindside gets lots of
hashtag love on tick tock
how are we
to Silo ourselves or to separate
ourselves out so that we can actually
find our desires find our wants
so there's a there's a interesting
exercise that I'll give people if you're
trying to find your purpose in life you
need to reach the end of thought
so if we look at where thoughts come
from
so thoughts come from two places the
indrias which are the sense organs in
the memory of indrias or India
experiences so if you kind of think
about okay like if I want a hamburger
what causes me to want a hamburger I'm
walking down the street I smell a
hamburger cooking then I start to think
about hamburgers
so thoughts usually come from the
outside
so I want to see this movie I want to
play this video game I want to watch the
show a thousand years ago did people
want to play that video game of course
not they never had a single thought
about it why do we think about it
because we get bombarded from our
sensory organs advertisers figured this
out too the yogis figured it out
advertisers figured it out brand
awareness
so if you want to find your purpose
but the thing is that stuff will
continue bombarding you as long as you
keep on inputting it into your senses
so this is where a simple exercise is to
reach the end of thought so if you go
for a walk
your mind will have lots of thoughts
you'll think about your calendar you'll
think about this I want to do this but
then as long as you don't feed your mind
it'll run out of those thoughts then
you'll have this period of boredom and
boredom by the way is your mind's way of
trying to trick you into getting
dopamine it's like we're starving here
give us something and so it bludgeons
you and Bullies you into giving it more
dopamine we see this with like binge
eating and stuff too it's going to make
you feel terrible because your brain has
figured out if I make this person feel
terrible they'll eat something
so you just have to reach the end of
thought and you just keep walking until
the thoughts run out
and then sit down hopefully on a park
bench and then just ask yourself what do
I want to do
ask yourself and then if all the
thoughts are gone you'll start to get
something floating from the surface and
the more that you do this kind of
exercise and meditation is a shortcut to
kind of do this by the way
I think the more you'll you'll discover
your purpose because you can't get it as
you said from crowdsourcing especially
internet and Google ads and cookies and
stuff like that because
it's not even crowdsourcing with your
best interests at heart
trying to separate ourselves out from
just how intertwined we are with
everybody else how intertwined everybody
else is with us uh is an incredibly
difficult feat and
one of my favorite blog posts of all
time is what do you want to want by
kailash and Rhoda and it's precisely
about this question that you're asking
here and um
he he has this bit where he says
if we don't step into our wants and
learn to program our desires then the
best that we can hope for is to become a
rich or famous slave
the cleverest rat in the room basically
allowing the entire world to tell us
what it is that we're supposed to want
asking yourself what do you want to want
is such an unbelievably powerful
question not what do you want because
what you want is informed by all of
those things societal Norms past traumas
parental expectations blah blah
what do you want what do you want want
in life when I work with people like and
once again like when we work with like a
lot of these high performing people
right they have a lot of wants but I'll
ask them where did that want come from
and or why do you want that and I think
you know when you start to really ask
that question that's when you really
discover oh I actually don't want this
like why do you want that I want this to
make my parents happy I want this to be
respected I want this because I don't
feel good about the person that I am on
the inside
so if I accomplish this thing it'll be
like an antidote to my low self-esteem
or my doubt
or my desire to prove yourself
like
prove yourself what does it approve
you're you you're always going to be you
you've always been you there's nothing
to prove
dude I love your work I I absolutely
adore this blend of modern Western
ancient Eastern I think you're an
incredibly impressive individual I think
that the work that you're doing is is
very much needed I wish that there was
10 of you out there or 100 perhaps but
for now we're just gonna have to do with
one I think uh Chris likewise I'm amazed
by your encyclopedic knowledge of just
all these different things and and being
able to pull from all kinds of stuff and
I I don't think we need 10 of us I think
one of us is enough
and I think what we probably need is
nine other people who have what they
bring to the table
right you have what you bring to the
table I I have what I bring to the table
we don't need more of me like not all
we're gonna get maybe maybe if we maybe
if we double to subscribe in them but
maybe that would be good maybe but I
think that there's probably nine other
people who are listening to this podcast
at some point who are going to be the
people that come after I agree we're
going to be grown up in your community
and maybe they go pursue a PhD or
something like that
and and I I appreciate the positive
sentiment I'm I really appreciate the
feedback you've nailed it you really
really nailed it I very very much
appreciate the intersection of
everything that you do if someone that's
listening has been blown away by what
they've learned today where should they
go to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do to find out more to take
some of your courses yeah so um
www.healthygamer.gg is like our you know
core website but I think a lot of people
usually watch our YouTube content so
healthygamer GG is our primary YouTube
channel we also have a Discord server
where we help people practice
you know skills that have socially
atrophied in the digital age like we on
Valentine's Day we had this um we had
300 people practicing how to ask each
other out
and and as as you mentioned before Chris
we were just talking about this I forgot
exactly what you said but I thought it
was brilliant if you want to just yeah
the the opportunity if we have uh VR in
future to be able to create a Sandbox
game I suppose that correctly programs
in somebody else's preferences a guy or
a girl's preferences and allows you to
be able to practice chatting up an AI
bot that would be able to understand
flirting and banter and humor and maybe
even body language and that went too far
and you know this would be great for all
sides as well because
you would be able to hopefully train men
to be safer with women not only safer
but more charismatic and more humorous
there is there is no apart from if
anybody has to ever review the game tape
of all of these poor people failing
forward with their terrible punch like
uh chat up lines there is no loser there
is no loser unless you believe that the
ai's got Consciousness in which case
maybe maybe the AI does a little bit but
even then yeah the greater good
absolutely and I I think that's kind of
what we're sort of devoted to not
necessarily AI but what we really try to
do is help the digital generation
understand their mind better and how to
how can we equip you to understand this
thing called your mind and sometimes
that involves helping your body and
things like that
but to really face the challenges that
like people face in a digital world
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you
would then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace